my ankle is actually it's fine it looks
really bad I saw the video back but
luckily I can push through anything and
I'm I'm dancing I hope he was better
than than Jordan so I had to cross her
up real quick and he felt really bad
when it happened - it was an ignorant
him injury on my behalf we attempted a
move that that we've never done before
and it didn't pay off clearly
immediately almost immediately I would
even say was anybody's fault like I
literally dig a toe touch it's like me
walking down the street and I rolled my
ankle like a lift or anything
luckily it wasn't as bad as normanni
Corday and Val Chmerkovskiy updating ID
on that ankle injury plus they are
teasing their Dancing with the Stars
finale numbers redemption dance is is a
quick step but it's a very like fears
kind of sexy is it is it's a very it's
kind of the last time you're gonna see
no money kind of bring it on the show in
that sense and now freestyle is is a
little bit softer sweeter it's more
beautiful I think it's more special it's
not necessarily huge in production as
much as it is an emotion and I hope our
audience really feels that there's a
section in my freestyle that I'm really
excited about yeah I don't want to give
it away just looking back at myself
watching the show with my grandmother
it's really a dream come true one to be
on the show but also to be in the finale
and be top three especially because I
worked so hard and I just really want to
make it memorable you know we've done
all that we could at this point and
we've proven to everybody but also
ourselves that you know we deserve to be
here but I just want it to be a very
happy moment and I want it to be
celebratory
you
[Music]